here it's a wonderful occasion so we
start by saying a few things about how
an ulzzang so back in the mid 80s I sort
of joined the tribe of people who would
see each other regularly in conferences
and workshops and many of the people in
that tribe are actually in this room but
Zhang who was one of them so kept seeing
each other over time in various
occasions and of course he followed all
of his work now the thing is that for
most of the people in that tribe I guess
age starts to take its toll and you can
see the difference but not with Zhang if
you look at that picture you ask is that
picture from 1980 something or is it
from today there's no really no way to
tell he has stayed the same had always
this very fresh-looking attitude but
it's probably also correlated with the
fact that he is one of the calmest
persons that you can see here ound very
even-tempered and at the same time
extremely thoughtful so there's a lot to
say about the specifics of Zhang's work
I think Kumar covered the ground very
well I would just emphasize that one
distinguishes it is his style of work
being to the point finding problems that
are both mathematically interesting that
also tell you something about real world
systems and an excellent taste in
choosing those problems now many of his
writings are great but still to this day
I often send my students to read John's
duquan
queuing networks because it has
everything in there but in the simplest
way possible the way that the starting
student can really understand what's
going on without getting bogged down
into all sorts of technicalities I will
not comment on the typesetting
everything else and that book is is
absolutely perfect so it's been a real
privilege of having this on going
relation with Suzanne meeting him all
the time and I'm getting perspective
about how one should think about
research and life so I'm going to talk
about the topic which might not
necessarily tell you so much about the
next wave of what's going to happen in
networks the next 10 or 20 years maybe
more of some good more esoteric topic on
the other hand it's something that jean
has done important contributions in so
therefore it kind of fits with the
meeting so it's about marks weight much
studied subject but I will try to look
at it in a slightly different way so I
had a conjecture about it and kind of
didn't really have any some initial idea
why the conjecture might be true but
couldn't really get very far asked quite
a few good people nobody grabbed it and
then I had a visiting student who came
from from Iran from Surrey University
kind of told him to conjecture a week
before he came so he walked in weeks
later and said that pretty much figured
it out how to do it after some
discussions and I had told him that if
that conjecture was solved then it would
have consequences on other stuff so I
told him okay so now you can start
working on the other stuff and he went
well yes I've already done it so it's
actually a really exceptional person he
is now back in Iran but he will be
looking for probably postdocs the fact
the positions hope to get in the u.s. it
depends the way things are these days
one doesn't know
happen all right so what is it about I'm
going to very briefly remind people I
guess almost everyone here knows a lot
about max weight some people know more
than I do but nevertheless I'll just go
thoroughly and to define what I'm
talking about
and then I'm going to embed the max
weight into a general class of dynamical
systems that has a structural properties
at one expand exploit get a general
result about dynamical systems and then
start to get the low-hanging fruit and
my claim will be that results on fluid
limit state space collapse and all that
there isn't really any probability
involved it there it's just a simple
consequence of a result about
deterministic dynamical systems with a
certain special structure under
perturbations all right so what's the
max weight policy if you have one server
at any time it can serve one of two
choose you serve the longest queue
that's the most trivial example of the
max weight policy generalizing little
bit think of having a network where you
have several no Jews that can be served
you can serve multiple queues
simultaneously but their interference
constraints so you cannot serve all of
them simultaneously
so typically you come up with schedule
that respects whatever non-interference
constraint you have so a schedule might
be represented by something like that
that says serve server to serve to
number to served to number four and you
only keep those schedules that are
allowed by the interference constraints
and and there's a finite set of such
possible schedules and at any point in
time you look at the state of the queues
and you're supposed to choose one of
them and what's the max weight policy
does is it looks at the cube vector at a
certain time and for any schedule it
looks at the so called weight of that so
with this schedule it would be the size
of Q 2 plus Q 4 you compare it with the
weights of the other schedules that are
possible and you choose one and that's
the max weight policy now this would be
the max weight policy if
never you serve a queue and you serve
the job the job goes away but if you
have a network actually jobs might not
disappear serving a job might mean that
it goes to another - and how does that
happens is determined by a routing
matrix so you want to serve things with
big weight but if you send them to a
queue that's also weighted you'd also
want to take that into account so these
are generally stands for a routing
matrix that represents where the jobs
will go and you also take that into
account in the calculation of the
weights so that's the policy and once
you have that policy the system evolves
as follows the next cue is what was the
previous two plus whatever arrivals
that's again a vector of arrivals at the
different use at a certain time and then
you have minus I whatever service you
give the service is your schedule but if
the queue has fewer jobs than what the
schedule gives you cannot serve more
than you have that's why you have the
minimum of Sigma and Q so that stuff
gets subtracted but because of the
routing other stuff gets added to the
queues so that's the these are the
dynamics all right so here's what my
viewpoint is going to be of courses
everyone most people here know that you
one can think of what's happening with
the fluid model in the fluid model we
replace the arrivals by deterministic
arrivals let's say we have arrivals at
UI at a steady rate of lambda I and the
system evolves deterministically so if
you have to choose and you serve them
according to serve the longest you what
happens is you're serving 1q exclusively
so one queue goes down but the other two
builds up because it get arrivals until
it hits the place where the two twos are
equal and once they're equal the max
wait policy he maintains that property
it sir it serves a little bit of this a
little bit of that in a balanced way and
it keeps going down so the deterministic
dynamics have this kind of simple
nature linear segments followed by each
other now if we have stochastic arrivals
what's going to happen is that you have
fluctuations and probably stochastic
arrivals are going to sort of follow the
deterministic path but there's going to
be fluctuations around them so we think
of max wait for a stochastic system as
being essentially a perturbation of
deterministic system where the
perturbation is due because of the
stochastic fluctuations of the actual
drivers around its mean so that starts
making think of traditional dynamical
systems you have a dynamical system plus
perturbations in on it what can we say
about the effect of those perturbations
okay in order to say something
non-trivial we need to exploit the
properties of the fluid system what kind
of properties does it have the drift is
piecewise constant in one region of the
state space you move it with a certain
drift once you hit that the agonal line
you start moving with a different drift
and so on okay that's probably not
strong enough to get any strong
conclusions there's another property
that comes in and that's useful it's
been known for some time I've seen it in
this paper Vijay I don't know if it goes
back even earlier but the idea is that
if you start the deterministic system
from two different initial conditions
and you let it evolve the trajector
distance between the trajectories does
not increase with time so that's a good
property because some sense it's a
stability property that should give us
something about perturbation not having
too large an effect so let's look at it
a little more
what does non expansiveness bias think
of a general discrete time dynamical
system where the mapping F is non
expansive so if you start from nearby
points the distance of the two
trajectories does not increase with time
and look at the perturbed version of
this where you add some perturbing noise
and you ask what's going to be the
effect of the perturbing noise okay now
here's the intuition each time my noise
is going to
a little away by a certain amount that
little away is not going to get
amplified because the system is not
expansive but each time I'm getting an
extra perturbation those perturbations
add up and so we can get very easily a
bound on of that form on the size of the
perturbation and if you are thinking any
reasonable setting where those user
stochastic or whatever because it's a
sum of absolute values these scales in
proportion with the number of steps that
we have on the other hand if you have a
trivial system let's say it's just
moving at a constant drift and you add
perturbations then it has a closed form
solution the difference between the two
trajectories is going to be just the sum
of the use without absolute values so in
a trivial system the effect of the
perturbation is the sum of the
disturbances and if the disturbances are
any reasonable kind of stochastic
process with enough assumptions this is
going to scale like the square root of T
so it's going to be much smaller than
what this was predicting and perhaps we
can exploit that but this is true for a
trivial system is it more generally true
that's the R which we would like to
establish to see whether for some
systems we have a property of this kind
that the effect of perturbations on a
deterministic system is bounded by a
constant times the sum with the sum of
the signed perturbations essentially the
term that we had there that would be too
much to hope if we have some
perturbations that add up for some time
and then they cancel each other the fact
that for some time they were nonzero
should have an effect so we look at the
perturbations up to time T the
cumulative perturbation but for any K up
to time T so this is my final time T at
some point in the past how big was the
cumulative perturbation this is our wish
to get a result of that kind and we can
we get to it unfortunately just having a
non expansive see
them is not enough to guarantee this the
simplest counter example is a system
that moves around the circle it's non
expansive but if you get positive
perturbations when you are up there and
negative perturbations when you are down
there actually the perturbations will
will cancel than each other but the
divergence between two trajectories
would keep increasing with time so
there's a simple counter example that
non expansiveness is not enough so we'll
probably need more properties about the
max weight policy so what we're going to
exploit is that max weight policy is
essentially the subgradient flow of a
nice potential function and here's what
let me try to give the intuition of what
I mean
so let's forget about boundary effects
for some time boundary effects I mean
when it you hit zero it cannot go
negative let's forget that effect then
roughly speaking the change in the
vector of Jews is whatever is coming in
let's pretend arrivals are deterministic
plus the effect of the service and you
subtract what you served you add where
the job where the jobs are going to okay
and Sigma star is determined by the max
weight policy by maximizing this
quantity with respect to Sigma okay I'm
throwing here this extra quantity
doesn't matter because Sigma is not
involved there what's that art max well
let's think of this potential function
which is this it's the quantity that
gets maximized where when you try to
find what service to use so let's look
at this quantity what as a function of Q
what kind of function it is for any
Sigma it's a linear function of two and
we're taking the maximum of several
linear functions of Q over the different
Sigma's and there's finitely many
Sigma's so that's our potential function
what is the derivative of this function
if I looked at the derivative at this
point in the vicinity of that point my
function is linear
and is given by this expression
according to whatever Sigma I'm using
the Sigma that I'm using of course is
the maximizing one so the derivative of
this function is linear in Q so the
derivative is going to be I minus R
Sigma minus lambda evaluated at the
maximizing Sigma so that's but that
corresponds exactly to that expression
this is the derivative of this function
its derivative it's the coefficient of Q
in this expression evaluated at the
maximizing Sigma therefore that means
that the max weight dynamics basically
evolve okay there's a minus sign
difference from when you go from here to
there that causes that so the
deterministic max weight dynamics are
basically the sub gradient flow of this
particular potential function so that's
an extra structural property that could
be useful it is as a gradient sub
gradient flow of a potential function
which is piecewise linear with finitely
many pieces it's convex and these are
the structural properties that we're
going to use so what can we say about
such systems let's take now let's
generalize consider an arbitrary sub
gradient flow of a deterministic system
which is sub gradient of something
that's piecewise linear and convex with
finitely many pieces consider an
unperturbed trajectory this is a more
precise version of what these
differential inclusion means it's the
integral version that's like the
derivative the derivative at each time
is must be an element of F and it's an
element F is a set because you might
have ties there might be multiple
Sigma's that are optimal so you choose
you choose between just between them or
a convex combination of them because the
dynamics here are non expansive this
system is well posed you get exists
uniqueness and so on and let's consider
now a perturbed system in which you add
the perturbation and consider the
perturbed dynamics again it's better to
put it in integral form so U of T is the
integral of the noise that you get at
each time that allows you if you want to
take mathematical tangents it allows you
to even perturb a system with Brownian
motion so U of T the integral
perturbation is a Brownian motion
whereas this thing would be quite noise
that we don't necessarily like that much
so we have a perturb that in our
perturbed system and the theorem is that
given any system of this kind there
exists a constant that guarantees that
the divergence between the two
trajectories is bounded by the magnitude
of the cumulative perturbation rather
than the sum of the noises at the
different times all right so one of the
reviewers said there must be an easily a
boon of proof or something and you
always enjoy those types of comments we
have no idea whether there's an easy
proof of the answers runs
pages and pages and quite complicated
and we suspect that there's no way to
get to an easy proof because the result
is very delicate if the potential
function had infinitely many piecewise
linear pieces the result is not true if
you take F to be a smooth strictly
convex function the result again is not
true so all the assumptions need to play
orchestrated just right to get that to
work let me just give you a little bit
of the idea of the proof so with the
piecewise linear constant dynamics that
you get from this potential flow the
state space is divided into different
regions maybe you start in an interior
you hit a boundary then you hit other
boundaries and you follow some kind of
strange path this is the
this is the deterministic system now the
deterministic dynamics when you are
let's say in the vicinity of that
boundary let's blow that up it turns out
that you can decompose them in two
pieces one is a drift along that
boundary that we have and another system
that kind of takes you towards that
dividing line and that one that
direction is orthogonal to the dividing
line and so this is just the constant
drift in my motivating example earlier I
said that for a constant drift it's only
the cumulative perturbations that matter
and then you have another system that
works orthogonal to that because the
drifts are different this is a hybrid
system it's not nice and simple one but
this is a subspace of one dimensionless
so what we get in the vicinity of this
dividing line is a simple system plus a
decoupled system that's of lowered that
hybrid but of lower dimension and now
that suggests that one should be able to
use induction on dimension you get a
result for all systems of dimension N
and then use induction to prove the
result for all systems of dimension n
plus 1 and keep going this way things
are not as simple that's what happens in
the vicinity of the boundary but when
you are in the vicinity of what they
call a critical point a critical point
would be a place here where it's not
just a band it's rather a point where
multiple boundaries meet then things
there become more complicated and you
need extra arguments to control how the
two trajectories behave in that vicinity
right so the nice clean elegant setting
that so it was my students are Salons
idea that instead of trying to study max
wait let's abstract generalize and get
general result which is absolutely
absolutely impressed by him so now let's
go back to max wait we have a fluid
solution which obeys the properties in
the theorem that I stated and we have a
stochastic process so what how are these
different the stochastic process is
perturbed from the deterministic one
because arrivals are stochastic there
are some extra complications the Q's if
they hit zero they cannot go below so we
need to also somehow take that into
account and also the Q's evolve in
discrete time whereas my general theorem
was for continuous time so you need some
extra massaging to take care of all
these details here and once you do you
get this result that applies now to the
max weight policy the distance between
the stochastic system and the fluid
system is bounded by the effect of the
cumulative perturbation what's the
perturbation it's the arrivals at time k
minus the mean arrival and then these
get added over time and you see how big
do they get in the horizon of interest
there is an extra term just because this
one is in discrete time that's in
continuous time when this one when an
arrival comes it just moves you away by
more or less lambda or so so the extra
terms come in to take into account the
fact that we're working in discrete time
okay so now anyone who's been in that
kind of business can probably guess that
once you have this result there's lots
of low-hanging fruit so once you have
this the proof of a fluid limit result
if you're familiar with this thing you
probably don't need to parse it because
you know what it says if you're not
familiar it's probably too many symbols
to parse in real time
but basically if you make a standard
simple assumption that my stochastic
arrival process as is a reasonable one
because iid processes with bounded
variance or whatever is straight
forwardly satisfies the properties of
this kind of laws of large numbers but
it's much it's much weaker than that as
long as my the fluctuations in my
arrival process are smaller than n n is
the time horizon scale in the time
horizon of n my fluctuations are less
than n typically for goods or gastic
processes it's more species will be more
like square root of n so this is
automatically small so if this is small
you just plug it in here and you get
that this is small and it translates
into something about the scaled cube
process following the fluid process as
we as we take the limit so the the proof
of the fluid limit result is one
paragraph or less exercise once you have
the deterministic result so that's
basically my claim that the stochastic
aspects are kind of simple even though
lots of technical ingenuity has gone
into that literature it's really a
simple deterministic property that's
behind it and one can then start to get
more low-hanging fruit so the business
that people do in this domain is to
start proving her state state state
space collapse results and instead of
giving all of the kind of detail here
let me just say that if you have a
system that's just marginally stable
what's going to happen so my total
service rate is equal to the total
arrival rate Q's will not go up and down
but the max wait policy will still drive
the to choose to be equal so I'm going
to be living somewhere on this set and I
will be fluctuation fluctuating on that
set that's what the state space collapse
property is but
needs to make it kind of rigorous okay
so let's make an assumption about our
stochastic process that large deviations
that is the cumulative being more than
the away from the expected value large
deviations have a probability that's
roughly 1 over F for some function f
once that function depends on what
assumptions you make for your process in
the standard large deviations setting
where you have finite moment generating
functions this F would be some
exponential because probabilities of
large deviations fall exponentially but
you might make weaker assumptions than
that so let's make a very weak
assumption that the probability of a
large deviation Falls like 1 over n a
very weak one then by plugging into the
deterministic results that we have we
end a little bit of extra work can show
that the fluid scaling of the process
with high probability stage uniformly
close to this subset of the state space
which is the state space collapse
property history about that devil rat
and Damon had made the conjecture of
this kind in their old big paper on max
weight Alf and all that with one we
managed to get the proof of this but for
the case of iid bounded arrivals and it
goes based on the apana functions
Lyapunov functions are great but they
don't work once you go outside the
independent setting you cannot make
martingale type arguments who are as the
in our setting we don't need any
conditions on the nature of the arrival
process it can be extremely dependent as
long as it has this qualitative property
that large deviations have probabilities
that fall at a certain rate that's all
we need so it seems to be a hammer that
can be used in
various ways and in the large deviation
setting F would be an exponential
function of n and that gives us a result
that the that the scaled to process will
stay close to the fluid limit for a time
interval that's exponentially large in
my scaling parameter n so typical state
space collapse results tell you that the
to stay closed over a certain time scale
with this result we can get it over very
long time scale and one can also show
that this is the longest that you can
have if you go to an even larger time
scale than the two trajectories a large
deviation would happen that would take
the two trajectories are part and give
sharp results okay some extensions and
realizations you can throw in weights
into the different use the same argument
seems to work we haven't written down
all the details but there doesn't seem
to be any hole that it also applies to
back pressure policies the more general
a generalization of max weight the work
the result does not quite apply if we
have max weight alpha as it's called
where you put a power of the Q vector in
there instead of the Q vector what gets
destroyed here is that this cannot be
expressed anymore as the sub gradient of
a nice piecewise-linear convex function
but maybe the end result might be true
with some different method we don't know
exactly what's happening there all right
so basically in conclusion it's here
what I presented is a nice simple gadget
it seems to be telling an interesting
property for a class of dynamical
systems so if you're just a dynamical
systems person this might be of interest
and it gives you some low-hanging fruit
and elementary arguments and who knows
results of that kind turn out to be
useful in other contexts in ways that
you cannot expect when you look at them
as long as there
clean and again that brings us back to
John's style to always look for
something that's clean easy to state
simple and see what one can get from it
and so on close at this point and again
congratulate John for entering a new
phase where he can be even more relaxed
but yea reset fails with infinitely many
kisses or kitchen can you is it easy to
describe no no it's okay so that counter
example is by our salon and I read it
and reread it and try to figure so if
you try to mimic the counter example
that I mentioned about the rotation that
things so but that's the rotation you
cannot express it as a sub gradient of
something so he has a potential function
that looks like kind of like a open book
but you add one more dimension and that
open book keeps rotating in space and
all that so just to describe the counter
example takes a few pages and he gets
that some description that's
quasi-convex and then he needs to do
have to reduce quasi-convex functions to
get equivalent convex ones though that
it's difficult
[Music]
don't necessarily I haven't looked at
those but for many well okay you know
the type of result of the framework the
framework might not apply they might not
fall in the class or sub sub gradient
flows that we have but that some result
of that type should be true the
divergences of the queues are limited by
the something like that should be true
but it would be a more complicated
argument and if at some point it ends up
being as complicated as the existing
proofs you have not gained something so
for these examples then this method
gives us a shortcut for other cases
trying to work that way might not be a
shortcut anymore more connor than
anything else to max without apartheid i
had tried some of these things with this
trying to extend previous version but i
got stuck because some of the equations
here to look at solutions only existed
for in sobel of spaces and things like
this you couldn't get things to work
with the more general continuous process
at that point I gave up
okay so it seemed to me that you his
picture you showed were corresponding to
sue people of linear functions but the
essential property used was that the
flow along the boundary is something you
can control
so you probably some easy generalization
where you're taking supremo functions
for which you understand the dynamics
but not in order to get the property
that the N minus 1 dimensional dynamics
are in a subspace that was foken or to
that alright well that not so good let's
take a break and thank you
[Applause]